Hi, this is Brittany for About.com...
...and these are some tips on how to pack your suit for business travel.
Start by putting your right hand to the jacket's right side sleeve...
...and pull it inside out.
Now take your right hand again...
...and stick the jacket's left sleeve back through the right sleeve...
...so that the cuffs are even.
Then, shake out the wrinkles.
Find the tag and use that as your center point to line up the collars.
Run your fingers down the length of the jacket to assure they are even.
Now bring the combined sleeves up on top of the jacket,...
...and from top to bottom, start to roll the jacket.
Remember to try and make each roll as smooth as possible...
...by pulling the wrinkles out.
And here's what it should look like.
Next, we will show you how to fold your pants without wrinkles.
Start by rolling from the bottom to the top.
As you're rolling, make sure to smooth out all the wrinkles.
Thanks for watching.
To find out more, please visit us on the web at about.com